stafford uneven district council is
currently consulting on its side
allocations plan and this short video
explains some of the proposals relating
to the centers of bidford or aven and
studly
within bidford proposal bid 1 seeks the
provision of a new center for the
village to the east of waterloo road and
south of wellington road
this is in recognition of the fact that
in recent years much of the development
in the village has been to the north of
the historic high street
which is now at the southern edge of the
village rather than at its heart
the proposed new centre is suggested to
include public space and a mix of shops
business commercial community and
educational uses
by focusing local facilities in a
location where they can be better
accessed will help the support a
thriving local economy
it is hoped that the proposal will also
help to revitalize the historic high
street as a destination for leisure
related retail activities
moving on to studly there are two
proposals within the site allocations
plan affecting the centre of the village
proposal stud1 proposes the location of
a new civic center to the south of the
high street
to include a range of uses such as
community business commercial
education and service facilities
proposals could also include an
enterprise centre providing specialist
workspace for local entrepreneurs
working or starting out in the digital
or creative sectors
as part of any development it will be
important to ensure that all existing
uses
and owners and occupiers on the site are
retained but in improved
premises benefiting both the businesses
and the wider village
delivery of the proposal will rely upon
the willingness of landowners
and the council will work with them and
the parish to deliver this
parish council to deliver this proposal
the second proposal within study center
stud ii
relates to the site adjacent to the
cooperative store on the high street
which has
been derelict for over 10 years the
council proposes to support the
redevelopment of this site to attract
businesses and jobs
provide affordable homes and improve the
environment of the centre
creating an attractive frontage to the
high street
you can find out more on each of these
proposals within bedford and studly
centres by viewing the site allocations
plan on our website
at www.stratford.gov dot uk
forward slash sapo where you can also
find out how to make your comments
we look forward to hearing what you
think about our proposals